a local church now revising its own
active shooter plan victoria saha
joining us live in studio now with a
closer look
churches have been targets for active
shooters before this weekend's incident
is just a reminder of how vulnerable
places of worship can be if they aren't
prepared
police are calling it a hate crime as
68-year-old las vegas resident david cho
allegedly opened fire at taiwanese
church-goers over the weekend but one
attendee now being praised a hero died
while trying to tackle cho others
followed that group of church goers
displayed what we believe is exceptional
heroism heroism and bravery that heroism
and bravery is what pastor john bain of
first christian church wants to enforce
among his parishioners if we end up in a
situation
i see almost everything it will be
handled back there but grab something
and start moving towards the exits
pastor bain says his church always has
armed guards by the exits and each
church member has an exit plan but now
that in-person service is back in full
swing he'll be revising his safety plans
with the congregation we're over to soft
targets and anybody that has anger or
hate in their hearts will come to a soft
target before they will a hard target in
his safety plan pastor bain advises his
parishioners to use whatever they can to
stop a gunman whether it be throwing a
bible at them or using a pencil to stop
them everybody needs to be attentive
to to their surroundings anybody that
comes in it's a hard thing to ask
because we welcome everyone during
larger services like christmas eve or
easter those armed guards also walk
around the church property to watch for
anything suspicious
for the safety of his church we chose to
not disclose too many details about
their exit strategy but pastor bain says
he hopes this weekend's tragedy will be
a reminder to always stay alert denise